picture yourself driving down a road
tomorrow heading somewhere to buy an
item you found on Craigslist perhaps a
nice mountain bike for $3,000 at that
price it's probably one of those bikes
with a little electric motor on it maybe
some streamers from the handlebars the
seller has declared this a cash-only
deal so you have in the console of your
car three thousand dollars suddenly you
are pulled over during the stop the
officer asks do you have any drugs
weapons or large amounts of cash in your
car you truthfully answer yes not to the
drugs or to the weapons but to the cash
in the blink of an eye you are ordered
out of your car the officer searches it
and finds your cash on the spot he
seizes it and he says he suspects it's
part of a drug crime a few days later
the local district attorney files
paperwork to keep your money permanently
and all of this happens without you ever
being charged or convicted of any crime
now you might be saying this would never
happen in the United States
incidents like this occur every day in
our country it's one of the most
significant threats to your property
rights most people have never even heard
of it's called civil forfeiture most of
you are generally aware of criminal
forfeiture although the term itself
might be a little unfamiliar so let's
begin with forfeiture when we forfeit
something we give up that thing or we're
forced to give it up in criminal
forfeiture someone is charged and
convicted of a crime and therefore they
have to give up property related to that
crime for example suppose you use your
car to transport and deal drugs you're
caught and convicted now you have to
give up or forfeit your car as part of
the sentencing that's criminal
forfeiture but in civil forfeiture no
person is charged with a crime the
property is charged and convicted of a
crime you heard that correctly the
government actually convicts an
inanimate object with a crime
it's as if that thing itself committed
the crime that's why civil forfeiture
cases have these really peculiar names
like the United States of America versus
one 1990 Ford Thunderbird
or the state of Oklahoma versus 50 3234
dollars in cash or my personal favorite
the United States of America versus one
solid gold object in the form of a
rooster now you're thinking how does
something like this happen that's
exactly what I said when I first learned
about civil forfeiture while on a road
trip with my wife no we did not get
pulled over I was reading about the
history of civil forfeiture as part of
my work as a research director at the
law firm and I came across one of the
cases I just mentioned the United States
of America versus one 1990 Ford
Thunderbird in that case Carroll Thomas
loaned her car to her son while in the
car her son committed a minor drug crime
Carroll didn't commit any crime so law
enforcement couldn't convict her and
take the car but they could and did use
civil forfeiture to convict the car and
take it
Carroll was completely innocent but she
lost her car nonetheless in other words
she was punished for a crime she did not
commit when I read this I was gobsmacked
how could this occur how is this even
legal it turns out it began in our
country with maritime law early in our
republic the government sought to fight
piracy yes actual pirates the problem
was the government often couldn't catch
the Pirates so instead he used civil
forfeiture to convict the Pirates
property and take it and therefore deny
the pirates their illegal profits of
course the government could have simply
taken and kept the booty without
necessarily using civil forfeiture but
doing so would have violated our most
basic due process and property rights
now the government rarely used civil
forfeiture until the 1980s and the war
on drugs
we expanded civil forfeiture law to
cover drug crimes
and then later other types of crime
Canada and the European Union adopted
similar provisions so that now all kinds
of people are ensnared in the forfeiture
web people like Russ Caswell Russ
Caswell owned a small budget motel in
Tewksbury Massachusetts his father built
a motel in 1955 and Russ took it over in
the 1980s during the years that Russ
owned the motel from time to time people
would rent rooms and they would commit
drug crimes Russ didn't condone the
activities in fact whenever he found out
about it he would immediately call
police Russ was entirely innocent of any
crime but that did not stop the US
Department of Justice from seizing his
motel simply because other people
committed crimes there but Russ's case
was not alone between 1997 and 2016 the
US Department of Justice took more than
six hundred and thirty-five thousand
properties this means each year tens of
thousands of people lose their
properties in cases in which they're
never charged or convicted of any crime
and we're not talking about not
necessarily talking about major drug
kingpins or headline-grabbing financial
fraudsters
whose cases involve hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars
many of these seizures and forfeitures
involve just everyday people like Russ
Caswell or you or me but it gets worse
are you wondering where does all this
cash and property end up in most places
law enforcement keeps it and they use it
to buy equipment or pay for building
repairs or even pay salaries and
overtime this is a clear conflict of
interest it creates a perverse profit
incentive that can distort law
enforcement and this is a problem that's
not lost on those in law enforcement
either former chief of police in
Rochester Minnesota Roger Peterson
described the choice that police
officers often face
as he described it suppose I'm a police
officer and I see a drug deal now I face
a choice do I go after the buyer and
remove from the street illegal drugs or
do I go after the seller and get cash
for my agency to use so it's easy to see
why police officer might go for the cash
it was just such a circumstance that
compelled police officers in
Philadelphia to seize an entire house in
Chris and Mark Ellis or valises son sold
$40 worth of drugs down the street from
their house $40 the police watched the
deal go down they could have arrest to
the buyer and confiscated the drugs but
they didn't they could have arrested the
sorav Ellis's son right there on the
street and grabbed $4 but they didn't
they waited to arrest him at home
because then they could seize their
entire house the house was worth three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars that
is what I mean by a perverse profit
incentive but the sword alice's case was
no outlier Philadelphia the City of
Brotherly Love the Athens of America the
cradle of Liberty birthplace to the
Constitution home to the Liberty Bell
and Independence Hall the city that
loves you back that Philadelphia was
running a forfeiture machine between
2002 and 2016 Philadelphia took more
than 77 million dollars through
forfeiture including 1,200 homes cars
jewelry electronics all of it they sold
the proceeds they kept and they would
have kept right on doing it had it not
been for a class-action lawsuit
our team's class-action lawsuit
[Music]
thank you we forced them to change their
forfeiture practices and to compensate
victims when our team first began
researching forfeiture in 2007 we had no
idea how much forfeiture revenue there
was back no one knew it wasn't until our
groundbreaking study policing for profit
that we found federal law enforcement
agencies have taken in almost 40 billion
dollars billion with a B since 2001 more
than 80% of that through civil
forfeiture unfortunately we have no idea
how much state and local agencies have
taken in because in many states they
don't have to report it so until we
reform forfeiture we'll never know how
much forfeiture activity actually occurs
in the United States and we desperately
need reform
legislators should abolish civil
forfeiture and replace it with criminal
forfeiture and all forfeiture proceeds
should go to a neutral fund such as a
general fund
when forfeiture proceeds stopped hitting
law enforcement budgets directly that is
when we will end policing for profit
now as you can imagine law-enforcement
officials don't love these
recommendations they stand to lose a lot
of money and they believe civil
forfeiture is an effective
crime-fighting tool the trouble is it's
not in June 2019 we released a study
that found forfeiture does not improve
crime-fighting and the report also found
that law enforcement agencies pursue
more forfeiture money during economic
downturns so when city and county
budgets are tight law enforcement will
use forfeiture to find the money so it's
no wonder then that law enforcement
officials predict a criminal apocalypse
if these reforms are adopted but some
states have already implemented them and
we're pushing for reform all across the
country because until we reform
forfeiture this is something that can
happen to any of us it can happen in the
United States it can happen in the
United Kingdom it can happen in
countries throughout the European Union
and beyond people like you and me and
the services and rusk as well just doing
the everyday stuff of life can be caught
in a scheme we never thought possible it
is time we end policing for profit once
and for all
thank you